[Music]
so this is the three circle anti-spin
fountain
notice that my left poi is making my
orange poi is making box ante spin and
it goes front behind front behind front
behind front behind front behind front
behind my body or in front of my body my
yellow poi is doing diamond ante spin
it's going behind front front front
behind front front front it's mostly
staying in front of me
it does half of that petal behind me so
it comes up behind my head then it's
around front up behind my head around
front so if you know box eighty spin and
diamond eighty spin and especially feel
if you're already are doing the two by
two by two by two and if you spin
fountain you should be able to pick us
up pretty easily if you can't do any of
those I recommend doing my online
courses it's step by step beginner
series beyond the basic series they each
have like 150 videos I put everything
into those highly recommended of course
also lots of free YouTube videos etc etc
so you can learn either way but I think
my courses are awesome but here let's
let's learn this so left poi clockwise
I'll face this way and you do your box
anti spin and each side of the box is
behind your body behind behind front
behind comes down behind your arm in
this side up behind your arm and that's
it so far so good you can start just
from windmill and focus on the two beats
at the bottom in front of you
but-but-but-but your left is leading
but but and what happens the left goes
behind the right doesn't the right takes
over and the right drops to the toes and
then the left goes over it so it goes
whoop right toes left over
buh buh right toes left over buh buh
right toes left over boop boop boop boop
boop boop now
messing with it as you come up this side
you're right boy has to start going from
touching a peddle out there and then up
behind your head to try to touch a pedal
hip right above your head right touch
but boom down out above boom down Oh so
for this pattern they're really coming
together in front they don't go down
down in front it's more like as the left
is passing here the Wrights come up on
this side and it's touching the sky
above you right lead left lead right
lead so the left feels the left leads at
the top the right leads at the toes as
the right touches the ceiling the left
is dragging down past your nose and as
the right touches the ground the left is
passing your nose from the bottom
the political pattern
despite a little bit of weirdness with
like weird stalker dude I'm beginning to
feel better now that now that I'm back
at Leviathan I really like it here
I really like the events we've done here
every year even though I always get like
half as many people as I need it's
always such a good time Nick also
reporting from the Bison where the
flowers are beginning to come up
[Music]